or Germany's defense Ministry says that
suspending all orders for the Army
state-of-the-art Puma armored vehicles
the decision follows crisis talks over
serious technical problems with 18 of
the tanks during a recent training
exercise the vehicles were supposed to
join NATO's spearhead response Force
next year now the Army says it will send
decades-old martyr combat Vehicles
instead Germany already has around 350
Pumas and they've made headlines for
their lack of reliability
well Alexander Miller is the defense
spokesman for the pro-business FTP group
in the German Parliament that party is
one of the Coalition Partners in the
government welcome to you help us
understand if you can what the exact
problem is there must be some quite
serious technical issues if all or
nearly all the Puma armored vehicles
break down at the same time or in
similar fashion
yes it is not nearly all they are all 18
all 18
um were out of order we were told but
that our ministry of Defense does not
yet know what exactly the reason uh is
currently those vehicles are on the way
to their home location in Reagan in
Bavaria and will be examined and by end
of next week they will tell us what
exactly were the reasons
the history of failures with these
infantry fighting Vehicles is long and
predates a lot of people's who's
currently involved in defense it goes
back some 20 years whose fault is this
this is a quick question
um uh the the the these vehicles in the
very beginning did not work very well it
was told those were children's uh
problems and it is a high complex
material built inside and very complex
software software modules that have to
interact with each other and those were
the explanations why it was so hard but
now we have an upgrade those 18 devices
were the newest version the newest
upgraded version the so-called vjtf
version of the Puma and we are just
trying to upgrade all our Pumas to this
upgrade version that we just tested and
if all those 18 were out of order there
are a lot of question marks now behind
putting money into this device again
many people say Vladimir Putin's Russian
army has been embarrassed on the
battlefield in Ukraine is this
embarrassing for Germany as a NATO
partner
of course this is embarrassing but you
have to know that um in a war condition
uh some of those systems can be
overruled um I'm not sure if everything
would be out of order then I'll give you
one example if for example the the
cleansing of the exhaust gas would not
work in peace conditions this device
will be set out of work but in of course
in war conditions we will continue
working with this and there are a lot of
things that could be the case we have to
wait until we know what are the reasons
but I think in war conditions it would
not be so drastical
yeah I very much take your point that
that it's a complex explanation but is
this at least part of the reason the
German chancellor has been hesitant to
provide tanks to Ukraine because they
don't work
no I don't know I don't understand this
Chancellor myself the reasons he tells
uh are not um obvious to me but this
would not be a reason for not giving a
thanks to Ukraine because we talked
about murder devices to give them to
Ukraine we never spoke about Puma
devices to give them to Ukraine
do you think Germany is ready to defend
itself or take part in the defense of
NATO territories
of course we are and what we um promised
to Nato and what we have to fulfill for
NATO is to have three fighting companies
ready
um and we have those we have the plan B
as the martyrs you already told it
enumeration uh that the martyrs would be
our plan B they work they work uh not so
full fashioned like the Puma who has
newer technology but the Mata is a very
good armored personal carrier who still
works
and in turn I guess I raised the
question for what does this mean for for
Ukraine can Germany support Ukraine
militarily
at this moment
so the parties in the bundesla's
struggle uh in this question that you
have some parties who say we we should
deliver uh even tanks even battle tanks
and armored vehicles uh from Western
production to Ukraine and we have the
social Democrats who say no and as long
as this is the case we will not deliver
and it depends uh on the on the
proceedings in the next weeks
Alexander Miller German lawmaker and
defense spokesman for the fdp in the
parliament thank you so much for your
time
my pleasure